and i'm pleased to have here on the rich
eisen show a man who
directed one of my favorite sports movie
in the rookie we just showed
my wife and i the blind side which he
wrote and directed uh to my kids just
the other day
uh loved uh the founder uh about ray
kroc and then the little things that is
now
available on blu-ray dvd right now with
denzel washington rami malek
and jared leto academy award winners all
the writer director
of this film john lee hancock here on
the rich island show how are you sir
i'm i'm doing great rich how are you
better for talking to you i don't even
know where to start with you
um honestly there's so there's so
there's so much to to get into
um let's let's start if you don't mind
before we get to the
the little things um some of the films
from from your past
uh the rookie how did you come across
the story of jim morris the pitcher that
dennis quaid portrayed so brilliantly in
the film
um mike rich uh
wrote the script and it was sent to me
uh by a friend of mine who was producing
the movie
alongside a guy named mark chiardi
who had played minor league baseball um
with jimmy morris way back in the day
not the second time around but the first
time around
and so mark had come across the story
in sports illustrated somebody said this
guy's making a comeback
this old dude and she already thought
wait a minute it couldn't be the same jd
morris but it was
and he secured the rights to jimmy's you
know jimmy's life rights and
i read the script and thought that for a
guy from portland oregon mike richard
did a really great job of capturing west
texas
um he had obviously spent a lot of time
down there and uh
and knew his stuff and it was the first
movie i directed so i was just trying
not to get fired
well you succeeded huh yes
well i mean it's it's so beautifully
done uh you know i i've seen it in
theaters i've watched it
once uh you know for like a third fourth
time in my life on a plane i'm crying
at 40 000 feet like literally tearing
up um and and you know for
i i asked this hesitantly um
because i like to think everything's
true and ripped straight from actually
happening
certainly in my favorite sports movies
the concept of him
throwing a fastball using a speed limit
sign
to clock himself and then not knowing
just how fast it was because it wasn't
operating properly the
the speed limit sign um did that really
happen
uh yes and no okay uh no it didn't
happen to jimmy morris but
mike rich swears that uh when he
had had a july july 4th barbecue one
time that he and uh
he and some of his uh friends had a few
too many beers and there was one down
the street and they took baseballs and
through and they swear that it gauged
numbers so i think years later when he
wrote the script he thought well that
would be a good way to let the audience
in on something that jimmy himself
doesn't know
and i just love the idea that he thought
he didn't uh
throw very fast then he walks away and
then the
the number nine the first digit clicks
in i
i get goosebumps just even thinking
about that sir
really i i re i remember you know it's
one of the things about
uh directing movies is you remember
exactly where you were when you were
shooting that
okay uh what what time of night it was
we were
in austin very near a high school that's
now been torn down
on a little tiny road but yeah you took
me right back there just said i love it
what time of night was it
john lee and cox it was probably we shot
that last
i think it was probably around 11 00
at night oh man let's get to the blind
side and again uh the little things
warner brothers the
little things written and directed by
john lee hancock available on digital
and blu-ray john lee hancock here on the
rich eisen show you
wrote the um the blind side as well as
directed it what about the story of
michael orr
um attracted you to that project
well i'm i'm first i'm a big michael
lewis man
and i'm always i'm going to read you
know books that that michael writes
and i had already done a sports movie
and wasn't looking to do
another one right you can they can you
can get in a rut
in a way in terms of the way hollywood
views you um
but uh gill netter the producer sent me
the book
i said would you like to read the book i
said i'm going to read it anyway so
might as well
they'll send me a first edition that
would be great and um
so i get the book and i start reading
and
i go oh man i've got a take on this i
like i mean i knew i knew i was going to
like it but i had a strong cake and i
said but they're not going to like my
take
because it was an unconventional
mother-son story
and um and so but i went and pitched to
fox and
and they said they said yes and we were
kind of off and running although it we
went through some fits and starts
it took it took years to get the movie
made and we eventually
had to get it get get fox to give it up
to us so we could take it to warner
brothers to make it but um i don't know
i just
i love lee into he and you know still
i'm really good friends with
sean and leanne and michael and all
those guys
so it was a great experience where is he
today how's he doing
what what's going on with michael he's
you know he has kids and
a wife and amazing you know still hangs
out with the two
some i'm not you know i'm not sure right
now if he's in
memphis or i think he's in i think he's
in back in baltimore
um living in baltimore how did you get
sandra bullock involved with that
john um well i everybody liked the
script
uh that i wrote um so you had different
agents talking about different clients
and she uh her name came up and i
thought that to that point she had done
mostly romantic comedies but i'd seen
her do some drama i thought she was very
good at it and i knew that
we would fail miserably if um lee and
tui
you know isn't funny we're dead that's
you know so i thought
that she could handle the the comedy end
of it as well as a drama
and so we met several times and uh
you know she really liked the script but
she said i don't i just don't know i
don't know
this this woman seems bigger than life
and unreal at the same time
and so i tell you what let's go to
memphis let's spend the day with leanne
and um and then you can make a decision
and you'll feel good about it and i'll
feel good about it
so we went to memphis spent the day with
leanne which is
always crazy and uh
you know with her with her with they're
going with their gun in the glove box
and uh double parking at the high school
and
driving 110 miles an hour to to go visit
uh michael in oxford and
uh you know everything that goes into
the day for leanne and at the end of it
we said goodbye and uh sandy you know
said
she terrifies me um
but but that's why i feel like i have to
do this movie because i'm i've been
around long enough
to know that those are those are the the
challenges that you're looking for
and she just crushed it yeah all the way
to the winner's podium huh
i mean all the way to the oscar podium
and i'll tell you this john lee hancock
um we showed it to my kids just two
weeks ago
uh the film holds up with the exception
of one aspect
that none of the coaches are where they
were
now they're all not even nick saban's in
the same spot
you know it's yeah you know uh where
yeah you know
the the coach of auburn's now in in this
u.s senate
it's crazy but that's the turnover of
college football you know so which which
one was the best actor
of the college coaches first
should point out that they were all
playing
they weren't playing themselves where
they were even at that point
was playing himself as an lsu coach uh
uh coach roger was playing himself as
the old miss coach and he'd already been
fired
by that point so everybody um
you know nobody was playing themselves
as coaching the team where they were at
that particular point
so they were all a blast yeah um
nick you know nick i think we had nick
had to work for a couple of days and so
he came in and he was early
and you know always on time and on it on
the phone the whole time
and uh and after we did we shoot like a
master of a scene it was a scene where
he comes through the door and his
meets the two family and so you shoot a
wide shot then you come in for what we
call coverage which is this is your
close-up this is your two shot this is
and it you know this is going to take a
half a day to get this
scene done so we shoot the master we
practice it rehearse it a couple of
times
and uh we rehearse it and then we shoot
one master i said okay we shoot another
master i said okay i think we've got
that let's move in and
we're gonna come in and cover sandy or
whatever
and nick turns and he goes wait we're
not done
and then he said no he goes you already
shot it i said well we have to come in
and break it up in pieces so we can edit
it together
and he said you guys need to talk to
some people you know
in the football photography world
because we don't get to do it multiple
times we get one time and you better
capture it all
and i said well as soon as that
technology exists i will be i'll be
right there with it nick
um
but the other thing about nick is that
he
he's the reason he's so good at you know
if what he does is he would say to me
after a take he would say don't let me
be bad help me be better
how can i be better no kidding yeah
which was impressive well now i could
see him in an aflac commercial and he's
got
he's clearly nailing that you know i
mean i think
you know that you could draw the lines
between the two here i coached him up
you did
but he was telling you you got one take
you take it
i love that so was he was he the coach
of the dolphins at the time
that he shot this movie no he was a he
was
uh at alabama and you put him in lsu
gear and he's like cool with that so
that's the last time he probably ever
wore lsu gear in his life
was in this film yes and what happened
was
i needed to get the real coaches
involved right and
lee anthony i was having trouble because
coaches didn't want to do it
and uh and i knew i needed nick saban
and so i had one i had a casting for a
nick saban lookalike
and i the guy came in and was it was
perfectly fine but i thought i know the
difference
and i sports fans have to like this
movie
they can't hate this movie so um i
called leanne and said
she goes how's the casting going and i
said you know i'm having a little
trouble
you know getting a hold of nick and she
goes i'll take care of that for you
it's like the blind side it's
unbelievable
and so i said so i get a call on a
saturday
my phone rings i answer it and he goes
just john hancock i said yes
he goes it's nick saban lee into he said
i had to call you
yeah and boom he's in the movie
on the roof he's in the movie and he
said i'll wear he goes but he said i'm
i'll wear my lsu stuff that i still have
packed away
said okay that's fine asked
i asked leanne i go how did you convince
him to do it
and she said i told him if he didn't
play himself they were going to hire a
short fat guy to play
wow
that is phenomenal oh the story's better
than i could even have hoped
that's incredible oh my gosh john lee
hancock here on the rich eisen show
let's talk about the little things um my
gosh uh denzel ramy malek
jared leto and a terrific film that
again people can get on
blu-ray and dvd and digital right now
um what how did you come up with this
concept write it
and uh and get all of these terrific
actors
in your employ for this um it it
it took a while i wrote it in 1992
um wow yeah i was just an idea that i
had i was very into
cop shows and crime movies and
procedurals and things like this and
this was
before csi and and all these shows that
we have on tv now that
are about procedural criminal procedures
um
but i uh came up came up with the idea
and uh
wrote it right after i wrote a movie
called the perfect world that clint
eastwood directed
this was the next one i wrote after that
um
and i don't it's been so long ago i
don't remember exactly what the impetus
was other than i liked you know crime
movies
um so that almost got made three
four times various directors and then
after i started directing
mark johnson our producer uh said well
you should do it you should do it
and i had kids that were little and it's
such a dark world to live in and when
you direct a movie it's a year and a
half of your life you know minimum
and i and i thought i don't really want
to live in that dark world when my kids
are little i'll because i'll bring that
home
and i don't want to do that and uh so
then my kids were in college and mark
johnson said you're out of excuses you
should do it
and uh warner brothers still owned it
and uh
next thing you know it was like they
said who do you want who do you want
to play joe deacon and i said denzel
washington why not why not shoot for the
stars right
and uh he said yes and then magically
everybody just said yes yeah
i got all my first choices you know uh
the three the three leads which was
never happened but i'm glad it did and
again it's available on blu-ray
um and dvd so again these three denzel
again you could just refer you know how
great somebody is when you just refer to
them by
by one name denzel washington ramy malik
jared leto
again from your from your your
filmography
um from saving mr banks the alamo the
founder
i mean you have directed tom hanks these
three
obviously sandra bullock emma thompson
uh billy bob thornton a couple of times
dennis quaid michael keaton
in the founder is there a through line
between these
actors actresses that that you as a
director have noticed
that makes them so great
yeah yeah first the the easy answer is
they're all incredibly talented
but it goes deeper than that they are uh
committed to excellence um they
when they show up they know that they're
creating something that's going to last
for a long long time
and they want it to be great because
they want
because you know if it's denzel for
instance
he's thinking about some somebody's
going to watch this movie in 10 years or
i'm going to watch this movie in 10
years
and i don't want to look at it and say
no i i i didn't go full
full speed on that play you know uh
so i just i don't know they're just
they're very they're very particular
um in choosing i think they also all
these people
choose their projects very carefully
because they understand
what they do what they do well and where
they won't excel
john lee hancock i appreciate the time
congrats on the little things i mean
it's got to be had to have been wild for
you
to direct this film now when it first
started in 1992 that had to be
re remarkably um satisfying to you
to do that it was it was it was very
it was satisfying but it was also very
strange because you're going back and
revisiting your mind from 30 years ago
because these are all things i made up
uh so it was a little
it was a little strange i'm glad i'm
glad i got to do it for two reasons one
just because i'd always enjoyed it and
wanted to see it made
and and two because i don't have to make
it again now i've
i bet uh thank you for the time those
stories are great i'd love to have you
on anytime you want i'm sure i've just
barely scratched the surface i'd love to
talk to you about your other projects
and
whatever project you have uh that you
want to promote i you've got a spot here
anytime thanks for the call thanks rich
i appreciate it you bet that's john lee
hancock go get the little things right
now available
on dvd and blu-ray wherever you can get
them
nick saban that's hilarious
how about that a short fat guy
we're gonna if you don't return this
guy's call
they're gonna get a short fat guy to
play you it's almost like the
the i have to call you is this john yeah
well leah said i have to call him i have
to call you like he got scolded
and had to call the school and apologize
because everyone's afraid of that woman
apparently so she got saban to do yeah i
mean
it seems like the movie version was
exactly you came down
that's why sandra bullock who said she
was terrified or she won the oscar for
man that's amazing i'm telling you the
movie does hold up with the exception of
like seeing
nick and lsu gear mm-hmm
and philip fulmer is viewed as because
you know the kids from tennessee is
viewed as like the
guy walking on water yeah
lou with lou holtz from arkansas great
movie
um tommy tuberville who's now in the u.s
senate telling people to stick to sports
instead of politics the guy doesn't even
know the three branches of government
but he's sitting there he's sitting
there in his auburn gear and how about
the fact that nick saban's like i have
my own
lsu stuff put away i'll use it
do you still have that you think yeah
michigan state and the cleveland browns
stuff like what
what dolphins is is nick saving a pack
rat yeah
i mean i don't know i know don's like
del tufo's wearing all this stuff so is
that are you saying that
del tufo is not the bill walsh of audio
but the nick's saving of audio
whoa because he says all that stuff i
mean he's a
what does that even mean uh bill
belichick oh geez
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here